hey it's pete i'm here in Silicon Valley
today and I'm talking to Vita ha who's a
co-founder of I feel good hey Peter how
you in today great good you excited yes
you pumped yes all right good so on this
episode of geek talk we're going to talk
to bita butter technology stack and we
have some really interesting things were
going to talk about some infrastructure
stuff we're going to talk about how to
stop and prevent online fraud which is
pretty cool we're going to talk about
some areas data related stuff that you
guys are dabbling in and using which is
cool and yeah we're just going to
generally geek out and have a good time
are you ready sounds great all right so
you're previously at Google right yes
and now your role here is co-founder of
I feel good and leave engineer lead
engineer okay cool so tell us a little
bit about I feel good what you guys do
just we have some context as to what
your application is and and what what
you guys are doing yes we are a digital
goods incentive platform so that's big
jargon to basically say we power the
redemption of free digital goods things
like Facebook Credits skype minutes EGF
gift cards anything that's instantly
redeemable that can be delivered
electronically um so that retailers can
offer them to consumers in place of
discounts okay so give me a typical use
case like how how a customer would a
customer's see or your service and a
purchase flow for an e-commerce site for
instance right so they would see banners
that we would host on the retailer site
that talks about the offer so maybe in
place of free shipping you would get
five dollars worth of free facebook
credits instead and then at the end of
the flow after on the receipt
confirmation page you'd see a widget
that's hosted by us um we actually do
the whole front end part of it also you
Facebook Connect click give you know we
know who your identity is then we
deposit credits directly into your
account okay so these could be this
could be an incentive alongside an
actual it could be a hard good that's
purchased with some sort of incentive or
digital promotion that you that's
powered by you guys exactly okay
you get the you get to use the Facebook
Credits immediately today even if it
takes a week for your new shoes or
whatever to arrive okay okay cool um so
tell me a little bit about your
technology stack what are you guys using
and what are you built on um we are
using ruby on rails as our web
development framework on top of Amazon
ec2 services all over the board and we
also have to know Facebook api's other
things like that okay um you mentioned
before you guys are using a lot of
different parts of the AWS stock run me
through those quickly there is easy to
which is the servers that we actually
run there's RDS which is our main sequel
style database we also use simple DB
which is more a more new flavor kind of
sequel database and then there's also s3
for storage so we use that both for any
kind of large data that we want to save
for offline processing as well as just
images creatives like things that go on
our website and our Redemption flow and
then we use a couple of the other
services I lost there is um the load
balancing layer that we use
automatically with amazon i really like
and messages yep okay cool yeah so
you're you're you're all the way in the
cloud do you have any servers at all no
you have a backup server somewhere no we
don't you can backup things in Amazon
like a lot of people use it for that
right s3 is cheap yeah they triplicate
everything typically so yeah I'm not
worried about okay okay cool um have you
ever had an Amazon outage just out of
curiosity no no we've been lucky enough
okay to not
to not be hit with that problem cool all
right well if Amazon's listening I'm
sure they'd like to hear that yeah